after 29 years working in polling
stations this should have been job's
30th but he resigned ahead of these
elections in protest at the new voter ID
rules working on this polling station
you tend to get to know the voters you
know who's coming in and out from year
to year it would be very difficult for
anybody to impersonate somebody else's
vote in Nottingham's heisen green some
people were being turned away today like
perner you had your ID but you're going
to have to go back and get yours yeah I
don't have a uni you need ID but I
didn't have a home but I'm not being
here Lal and his wife were also turned
away I had my ideas your password but he
didn't accept
so I bring it original one
because you had it on your phone but
they said you needed yeah but you need a
paper cup yeah but ten minutes later
they were back an eager to vote
others like Bugsy were ready for the new
rules it does make Royalton a little bit
more secure writing you know because
there are so many folks who want to
wiggle around under on the results make
it more than questionable whereas with
water ID that can't really happen I
suppose I find a way around it in the
end you know what who knows
five minutes down the road some voters
were unclear about the requirements here
Niam left her native Sudan in the 90s
and worries many aren't aware of the new
rules my daughter she's a university she
she told me mom she called me she said
she should take you ID every woman she
should vote because in our country the
woman she doesn't have voice but in this
country I think we we should working
together to help this country
it's thought between one and three
million people may not have valid ID
the data on who these voters are is
mixed and complex though with several
different groups potentially affected we
spent about three hours at two polling
stations in this area and have seen
around 10 people who've been turned away
for not having the right ID now half of
them did come back and while no one
seemed that annoyed by any of it you can
see why some are worried about the
impact these new rules might have
one of the city's MPS says with few
recorded instances of voter fraud the
policy isn't needed it's a very
expensive solution to a problem that
doesn't exist
and then you've got to look at why the
Tories are doing this it's because they
stand to benefit because a lot of those
people who are less likely to have photo
ID are also the same people who are less
likely to vote conservative it's an
attack on democracy and it really
amounts to voter suppression
ministers fiercely deny this and say the
new rules will ensure elections are free
and fair pointing to trials showing next
to no impact on turnout
labor will almost certainly keep
Nottingham in this local ballot it may
take a general election for the full
impact of these ID reforms to become
clear though Rob power Sky News in
Nottingham